- She thinks I'm doing a
puppy video right now so...
I have been considering getting a tattoo
for a few years now.
- It's crossed my mind, my
parents don't know that.
They both like never had any tattoos.
- I have occasionally
brought it up to my mom
and she freaks out.
- I'm actually kind of worried that
he's going to lift up his shirt
and be like me too, twins!
I'm going to be like no Dad, it's fake!
- She might deny that it's real
or she could burst into tears,
third option I guess that she
could have a heart attack.
- The tattoo I'm going to be getting
is a flower, really girly and cute.
I think it's believable.
- I really hope that you have
an ambulance out on standby.
- [Interviewer] How was Dasha growing up?
What kind of a kid was she?
- Dasha was a smart girl, very practical
and didn't get into a lot of trouble.
- I think Jennifer was
born Miss Independent.
From the very beginning
putting her in a stroller
and she wouldn't stay in the stroller.
- Our relationship has matured
and I think I could
tell you more things now
which is good.
- I think we're fairly
honest with each other.
I mean I don't think we
share every little secret.
- Yeah, I think I should tell you.
- Uh oh.
(laughs)
- So I don't know how
you're going to react.
- I got a tattoo.
(laughs)
- You're full of it.
- I swear to God.
- Show me.
- Am I allowed to like
lift up my shirt on camera?
- Are you, are you joking, is it real?
- It's a tattoo!
- Oh my god!
When did you get that?
- A few weeks ago.
- Is that real, Jen?
- Yeah.
- Is that permanent, where did you go?
- Santa Monica area.
- You know hepatitis gets trans--
- See it's a flower, it's cute, right?
- Well I don't know, looks like a wound.
- Oh great!
- Why do you do look so upset?
You look like you're going to cry.
- You look like you're crying.
- Well you're making me
feel shitty now about it.
- Well it doesn't make me happy.
- It's not on you.
- Damn right it's not on me.
- I just like felt inclined,
thought it was really cute.
Maybe had a little bit to drink.
- You didn't think about asking me
or calling me or telling me or anything.
- No, I was kind of worried
that you'd be upset.
- Well it's, no I just
don't like that location.
- Uh huh.
- I think it doesn't look good.
- Everyone else in the
family knew about it.
- Everybody else knows?
Your dad knows?
- Dad knows, Jonathon knows.
- Great.
- Did you ask anybody else
about it or you just did it?
- Yeah, I thought about
it, like some friends
to see what they thought,
they said it was cute.
- They might not let you
in the convent anymore now.
- Yeah I know, I don't
know what I'm going to do.
I'm kicked out for sure.
- If Jennifer had asked me first
if she could have a tattoo, I mean she,
she's older, out of my control,
I mean I'm not thrilled but I'm not,
there's too many other things that are,
that could be far worse so...
- I have more thing to tell you.
- Is there another thing?
- Yeah.
- But I hope that in the future
that if you want to do
something drastic like that
that you'll let me know.
- Okay, I'll make sure moving forward.
- I'd feel better with that.
- But I have one more secret actually.
- Okay, what?
- It's actually a fake tattoo!
- It's fake?
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- And you didn't tell your dad?
- No I did not tell Dad, Jonathon.
- Oh, you are, you're such a great liar!
- Did you really hate it that much?
- When I get past the fact
that you're my daughter
and you did the tattoo now.
- Uh huh.
- And I want to like critique that art.
- So I should run it by you.
- I appreciate it when Jennifer calls me
and wants me to be with her for whatever.
- So maybe I'll go get
a tattoo after this,
you want to come?
- Only if I can get a matching one.
- Perfect, let's do it.
(laughs)
So for putting you through this.
(mellow guitar music)